الفعل يعني راويه عام كامل على المعارك
هنا في اوكرانيا
وتستانف القوات الاوكرانيه القصف العنيف
على مدينه دانيت بالامس قتل سته واعداد
كبيره من الاصابات هناك قصف بصواريخ
هايمرز استهدف المدينه وضواحيها القصف
المتبادل طبعا القوات الروسيه تقصف ربما
هنا لدينا احد المواطنين ربما نسالها عن
يعني شعورها بهذا اليوم
تقول بان عام كامل من المعارك وكل يوم
يعني يزداد العنف في هذه المدينه
يعني قضى نيو ان شاء الله يعرف
تقول بانها من حي كوبشكي وان هذا الحي
يتعرض للقصف بشكل يومي وبعنف تسقط فيه
وبكثافه القذائف الاوكرانيه وهي لم تترك
بيتها
تقول بان مرتين صواريخ جراد سقطت في بيتها
تحديدا
تقول بان يعني القصف او الصواريخ احدثت
اضرارا كبيره في منزلها
[موسيقى]
وتقول تقول بان المعارك مستمره
يعني القصف يخلف ضحايا وقتلى بشكل يومي
ولا يتوقف جيران يا كاكاونتي
تقول تقول يعني انا اتمنى ان يتوقف كل هذا
وتتوقف الحروب انه مرعب جدا ويعني استمرار
نعم راويه